this video answers the homework
questions I said in my previous video
called understanding quantum mechanics
if you're new to my channel you probably
think it's extremely naive of me to set
homework questions
no one's obliged to do on YouTube videos
that no one's obliged to watch and it
probably is naive but I just don't
believe that learning is a passive
process even if you never do answer the
homework questions I hope that me asking
them prompts you to think and I hope
that this video will be useful to you
because it'll cover the common
misconceptions from the original video
and I'll also answer the most frequently
asked questions
okay so the first time went question was
can you do the double slit experiment
with large objects and still get an
interference pattern
remember in that video I said that
objects only act strangely when they're
not being measured
but this doesn't happen for a big object
because it's constantly being measured
so the straightforward answer to this
question is just stop things from
measuring it
but is that possible people pointed out
that if an object is made out of lots of
particles wouldn't the different
particles interact with each other
and what about gravity every object is
interacting with other objects via
gravity and so doesn't that mean that
nothing can escape being measured
there were lots of great questions along
these lines and somehow they all boil
down to this bigger question what is a
measurement this is easily the
million-dollar question in quantum
mechanics and it's still unsolved and so
we're going to talk about it in lots and
lots of detail in the main series but
for now I want to address a
misconception that I can debunk that I
saw in the comments a lot people thought
that when I said measurement what I
really meant was interaction in other
words they thought that if a particle
interacts with another object it has
necessarily measured it and I can see
why you would think this since all my
examples of measurements were about
particles hitting other particles but
this is not necessarily the case
actually a measurement is when you get
information about what the particle is
doing leaking out let me explain
in one example that I showed the object
is hit with an air molecule but the
point is the air molecule will change
its own path depending on where the
object is if it's here it'll bounce off
like this but if it's here then the air
bounces off like this and so since us
seeing the final state of the air
molecule is enough to decide where the
object is we say that the air molecule
is carrying away information about the
object's position
and that's what makes this a measurement
not the fact that the air is interacting
with the object but that it's leaking
information about the object to the
outside world
let me explain this point a little bit
further with another example suppose
that you have some weird hypothetical
thing that changes color when it comes
into contact with our object but it goes
straight through it this is clearly some
sort of weird interaction now say the
object can be either here or here again
and the thing comes in like this in
either case the final state of the thing
is this the thing clearly interacted
with the object but it hasn't measured
it since it gives you no information
about where the object is that's an
important point so I hope it's a bit
clearer now now let me get back to the
question about when our object is made
of different interacting parts both
simplicity imagine our object is just
made out of two bits stuck together if
one of the bits is in this position then
you know that the other bit has to be
here too
and similarly if you know one part is
over here then the other bit would be
there too and so clearly this one bit
does contain information about the other
the reason this doesn't count as a
measurement though is that this
information isn't being leaked out to
the wider world and so for it to count
as a measurement in quantum mechanics
it's really important that the
information be carried away and you can
no longer interact the two particles
together there's a reason for this and
it's something I'll cover in detail in
the main series but for now let me
convince you by appealing to experiment
the double slit experiment has been done
with many things made of of composite
parts many of you mentioned they've done
it with buckyballs which are molecules
with 60 carbon atoms and still saw the
interference pattern but apparently it's
been done with molecules with over 800
atoms as well and it still works so
composite systems can have interference
another great question I got a lot was
what about gravity does that count as a
measurement to
answer this I'd need to assume just
slightly more quantum mechanics than
I've taught you so I'm gonna set this as
a homework question in the third main
video of this series and you guys can
give it a go for yourselves then and
I'll give you my solution in another one
of these videos but getting back to the
actual homework questions now the second
question was imagine if you had some
measuring device that could actually
measure which door an electron went
through what would happen remember I'd
said that electrons acts strangely when
they're not being measured but right now
it is being measured and so it has to
act normal again for an electron that
means that it has to be in just one
place you won't see it go through both
slits just the one but doesn't this
contradict what I'd said previously
since now we know each electron is going
through just one door
no because now the pattern on the wall
is no longer the interference pattern
instead it's exactly what you'd expect
in the case each electron goes through
one door which is what's happening in
this case quantum mechanics is sneaky
question three this one's about bohmian
mechanics and I'll keep it short because
I've talked myself hoarse about this
serie before the question said in
biomechanics aka pilot-wave theory the
electron does in fact go through just
one door in the double slit experiment
but in my last video I seemed to rule
out that possibility
so what incorrect assumption did I make
when we looked at the single slit
experiment we saw electrons go vaguely
here so we assumed that if electrons
were really going through one door each
an electron going through door one
wouldn't mind whether the other door
happens to be open and it would just do
what it was going to do anyway and end
up vaguely here in any case that's how
we got a contradiction but that's not
the case in bowie mechanics though the
electron does go through this one door
but it cares a lot about whether the
other door is open that's because it has
this thing called a guiding wave that
spreads through all of space and tells
the electron which way to go so when
both doors are open the wave goes
through both doors and then tells the
electron to go somewhere else
okay so those were the main homework
questions let's have a lightning round
of responses to other common comments
last doesn't the single slip pattern
actually look like this with one main
band and a few fainter bands on either
side whereas I always draw it as this
the answer is yes I just draw the main
chunk because it's easier and clearer
but I could have done it properly and
nothing would have changed in any of my
arguments next there were lots of people
who try to answer homework question one
by using this equation called the de
Broglie wavelength I made a video about
the uses and abuses of that equation but
basically that equation is only valid in
very very specific circumstances and one
that almost certainly doesn't apply to a
complicated real-world object
also I got a lot of comments saying that
I was wrong about waves because of
quantum field theory or that I should
talk about quantum field theory instead
because all the paradoxes clear up when
you look at it
actually I think the paradoxes of
quantum mechanics just get compounded in
qft but that's something to talk about
much much later
and that's all for this video thank you
so much to everyone who did leave a
comment on my last video and I really
encourage all of you to give the
homework questions ago in the future but
unfortunately while I love reading and
replying to all the comments soon it
will be too much for me to reply to each
one personally I'll keep reading them
all and I'll reply to as many as I can
in the future but that's where I'd love
for all of you to help me and comment on
each other's work as I saw in the
comments last time that leads to way
more interesting discussions anyway I
try to ask questions that can be
answered in multiple ways so you guys
can learn from each other and this works
when we all treat each other with
respect and remember that we're all here
to learn thanks guys see you for the
second proper video in this series
you